the Las Vegas Arts District certainly
has a lot of history in fact many of the
buildings are considered historic but
for some who own businesses around there
they may feel as if some of that Arts
District Vibe is fading away thanks for
joining us here at 11 o'clock I'm Denise
Valdez eight news now reporter Madison
Kimbrough spoke to some business owners
who share their thoughts she joins us
live now tonight from Main Street with
more Madison
yeah the arts district is all about
culture but a lot of local businesses
feel as if restaurants and breweries are
taking over and a lot less art is
happening here take a look
just recently the Old Mission Linen
building on South First Street was
bought by J Dapper who owns several
properties across the valley
including the historic hunt Rich theater
that's under Renovations Wednesday the
city will discuss making the Mission
Linen building an official Las Vegas
historical site but with all this
history many feel like the arts district
is losing its feel and forcing higher
rents your rents are higher down here I
know several places recently their rents
were tripled Bobby Ann Howell is a
program manager at Nevada Humanities a
non-profit Social Services Group located
in the arts district for over a decade
she feels the Arts aren't the focus
anymore I just always wish there's room
to keep the Arts as part of it and you
know maybe that there was some incentive
or something from the city or something
to help our landlords make that money
and over at Fresca's skate shop on Main
Street owner Amanda Quintanilla agrees
even though her roller skate shop is new
to the district she's noticed a shift in
the type of businesses opening up I
believe the Art District again is very
unique and we should have more
uniqueness in here and all we see is
more
food more beverage but over at the
English hotel which just celebrated
their year opening in March general
manager Steve Dennis insists their goal
is to preserve the art culture the
district is known for what we've tried
to do is provide a platform for all
these local artists whether it's on the
fence outside inside art such as this to
present and display here at the property
I used to manage a couple hotels here in
town and I would be wary to actually
drive through this area of the daytime a
decade ago now it's a walking area it's
a Park area it's an area that families
can come to
as for what's to come of the Mission
Linen building it's unknown at this time
but developer Jay Dapper bought the
building in August for 7.5 million
dollars now as for tomorrow the historic
preservation committee meeting will take
place at noon reporting here live in the
arts district Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now